Harry Dunn's parents are still fighting
to get justice for their son in the
Commons
finally some answers as to what the
Foreign Office knew about an cyclists
leaving the country we were made aware I
think it was a day or two before I can
check and we registered our strong
objections nonetheless and I think it's
very important because she suggested
checks at ports or that we should
immediately have tipped off the police
it would have been unlawful to arrest
her and the Vienna Convention on
diplomatic relations so that would have
I think you can all agree not have been
a responsible or productive thing to
have done indeed it would have been an
illegal thing to do
diplomatic immunity enabled an cyclists
to return to America after the car she
was in crashed into Harry Dunn's
motorbike as she allegedly drove on the
wrong side of the road and we now know
that UK objections to stop her from
leaving the country had no effect
America refused to waive immunity but
while foreign minister Dominic Rob says
a review is now underway to stop those
rules from ever being used in the same
way again Harry's family dispute that it
was legal to claim it in the first place
all this time that she did have immunity
is not something that this family
accepts that they have clearly good
advised that what the Foreign Secretary
is saying is this is simply not true
although the Foreign Office insists in
mr. Sark ulises case
diplomatic immunity was relevant and
pertinent having been kept in the dark
for almost three weeks about the fact
she'd even left the country the family
has lost faith
so far they've described every meeting
they've had with officials as seeming to
be photo opportunities or in the case of
the White House's attempts to engineer a
meeting with mr. Sark Ulis and ambush
for Harry Don's parents the grief at
losing their son has only been
compounded by what they see as a lack of
justice and a lack of respect
Katie Spencer Sky News